en tant que de rui des doyens je dois
faire face à mes responsabilités
[Musique]
toutes ces années sans accroc pas une
fois je ne suis même tordu la cheville à
bas les soirs il a d'un coup sans
prévenir
à partir de maintenant je ne doit plus
être le seul à connaître la formule de
la potion magique oui je vais donc
partir à la recherche d'un jeune
successeur à qui j'enseigne ray la
recette de la potion magique et qui
deviendra le nouveaux bruits du villa
3-1 et parle d'une recette
qu'est ce que tu racontes pourquoi
est-ce qu'on choisit forcément le plus
fort ban pour l'écouter au bras toutatis
serait soit ma vie te tue entre la
ballon la secrète ou les pommes pousse
toute la nuit
ehpad pas une recette avec des pommes
une tarte aux pommes la rigueur attendue
pas d hier que tu as bien compris ce
n'était sûr que tu penses hourdin june
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
c'est une question si c'est un autre
druide qui fabrique la potion magique
est ce que j'aurai enfin le droit de la
côte est